so I don't know if you know this uh
because we spoke you know in Brazil uh
for a while so the video I don't know
this is not what meant the way I meant
to start the interview but remember the
video I shot of you where I was talking
I have never seen s first of all it went
everywhere I don't know if you're aware
but the thing that really was just
really cool was that every single person
who like talked about it or retweeted it
was like even some of them were like I'm
not the biggest Zack Snyder fan but man
this is awesome things like that
like I've never seen so many people so
positive about something and so can you
sort of touch on that because it went
everywhere yeah I don't I I look I I
didn't even I didn't know that I mean
you you mentioned it to me on the day
but we've been so um you know spun out
on this tour I never really had a chance
to reflect on it um except to say that
you know
it's weird
because in the scenario I was presented
with this thing of like oh these we're g
to we have this setup where we can put
these guys in this movie in in the
trailer sure and you know would you help
them would you direct them I guess is
really the thing I I don't know what
that means exactly but you help them not
look crazy you know and I and so I I I
was like yeah absolutely happily happily
like and and I think that that it's fun
it by the it's no different than doing a
normal shot in a movie you know in some
ways once you can kind of like shut
ComiCon off that's behind you and just
kind of you know be with the be with the
person that's there and try and you know
they're doing their best and I was doing
my best you know so yeah I think that
that I think that it was uh it was kind
of U it was kind of it was fun for me
I'll be honest you know I I don't mind I
should also say that uh there were a lot
of people who also said this is why Zach
is the goat you know just want to be
clear that there was a lot I've never
just never seen so many people so
positive about something well I mean it
was cool and it was a cool by the way
I've never been in a scenario I mean
it's a sort of Perfect Storm of like
okay here's the camera we have this cool
background we have this idea to put the
people in I'm there so like I guess
we're just gonna make a shot so it was
like it's cool I I don't i' I've never
had an experience like that before I I
don't know I don't know that we could
have manufactured it um knowingly you
know what I mean it kind of happens
those things kind of happen like I think
you know I don't want to be sound like a
jaded but like I think those things just
happen if you do it if you do it if you
have all the Alchemy correctly that that
can happen so sure also no director of
your stature has ever done something
like that at ComiCon but let's move on
to Rebel Moon ni so with the thing that
I'm listen you've talked a lot about
both films or both you know Rebel Moon
one but I have to ask in Rebel Moon one
and rebel Moon part two what is one
thing in each film that you like cannot
wait for people to see I think in Rebel
Moon one I think that the thing I'm most
excited for people to kind
of get caught up to the fact that by the
time they're on the journey with Kora to
track these guys down and bring them
back to the Village you know when
they're when we're we're in that mode of
searching for the the guys that will
fight with them
like it's it's cool to wake up and be
like oh shoot we're in that kind of a
movie we're like really in it we're
going to get these guys we're really
gonna we're really gonna we're really
setting up for like a war movie here um
and the cool thing is is that there's a
slight misdirect you know there but the
thing that I'm also super excited about
is in Movie 2 is the is also the moment
when you realize that you are in that in
that movie you thought you were that you
were headed for you know and I think
that that is uh that's what I'm excited
about it's the sort of culmination it's
it is a two it's a two book set you need
book two you know which is fine I I have
know that you should know that you know
it's the first episode you know you need
part two to know where we go and so yeah
I just I love that you're going to the
the investment that you make in movie
one pays dividends in movie two pretty
heavily so um I know that the originally
you came this was an original Star Wars
idea and obviously it it became Rebel
moon but you do have a nod to Star Wars
at the very beginning of Rebel Moon part
one oh sure and so can you sort of talk
about was that um like is that an
intentional notd to Star Wars like how
did that opening shot happened how did
you decide to do it yeah uh we needed
like a transition down to the planet and
it just felt like this tilt down to the
to the the planet felt like the the easy
way to do it there's a little bit of
irony in that it it feels like the tilt
down is in space but then when it lands
it's actually on the ground so I thought
that was kind of a a a a slight like
curveball for the classic you know
Planet reveal that they we kind of used
to um but I just thought I just you know
I dig the language and I dig the sort of
everyone knows what it is it's not like
a it's kind of comforting in a weird way
because you're you know you feel like
okay I see where we're going I I I I I I
get this this vocabulary and you have to
be I feel like you have to walk people
into that stuff you know you can't just
like slap them you have to give them a
little bit of like give them a little
bit of familiar uh ground to to to to
stand on at first and then you can kind
of go nuts so obviously you've done a
lot of cool in your career but when
was the last time and it might have been
on this movie but when was the last time
the night before you were filming
something you were like genuinely
nervous like how are exactly we going to
do this yeah no that happened a lot on
this movie um you know being the
cinematographer and the director on a
movie like this either one of those jobs
is nerve-wracking on its own um but uh
there was plenty of days that we were on
this movie that I it's funny in Movie 2
we harvest the crops right and uh it's
kind of like a Days of Heaven sequence
in the middle of the movie and
I you know that was all like weather
dependent and we had to have these great
sunsets and all this stuff we were
hoping for you know and you know there's
no wood around here but uh you know we
were worried that we wouldn't get it and
you know thank God we had a lot of great
a lot of great moments in the in in the
in the harvesting
sequences but that stuff I was really
nervous about because we' grown this
wheat for months and and it was golden
and perfect and we were just marching
into this giant weed field to chop it
down with all of our actors who didn't
know how to they were learning how to
side and all that so like I didn't know
like how good they would be at it and
they were great and it was amazing so
yeah I plenty of times I was nervous I
just want to point out before we wrap
that I literally out of the corner of my
eyes I saw a spaceship going across the
screen and I'm like wait what is going
on here well you know Netflix uh they
they didn't mess around with this no no
not kidding on that note sir I really do
hope it's a huge hit and uh I can't wait
to see part two thank you so
much